non
[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue à la rivière
saint-louis fait chez moi et aussi à
l'atelier l'entrée suivez-moi
je m'appelle et me dit fontaine j'ai 34
ans je viens d'arriver à saint-louis
j'ai deux enfants et j'ai créé l'atelier
landecy
je viens d'une famille assez modeste
dans laquelle j'ai dû être séparés à un
moment donné dans mon adolescence
puisque j'ai été victime de traumatismes
et d'inceste pendant plusieurs années
et je n'avais pas non plus eu l'occasion
de poursuivre mes études comme il se
devait quand j'ai eu
ma petite fille j'ai senti le besoin de
faire quelque chose de concret pour la
faire grandir et je me suis rappelé de
justement de toutes ces passions
artistiques que j'avais qui sur le vers
lesquels je me suis retourné pour créer
mon atelier je n'ai absolument lui
aucune aide pour réaliser quoi que ce
soit ni pour acheter mon matériel il ya
que là en fait ces derniers temps que
j'ai pu mettre en place certaines
demandes auprès de l'abbé jeu de la
mairie du département également pour
pouvoir justement m'aider puisque je
sens bien qu'il est temps pour moi de
faire de s'agrandir cette société en
fête ou de faire quelque chose
c'est un atelier de fabrication
artisanale 100% fait main où je propose
des vêtements des accessoires de la
décoration et ça va toucher plusieurs
arts donc il y aura de la couture du
crochet la broderie du tissage et au
niveau de la décoration je vais proposer
d'autre part comme le chant tournage la
gravure le tour à bois ou la peinture
acrylique j'apporte une conception de
bijoux uniques pour le moment donc
s'agit de bois et de résines ou qui
seront conçus et adaptés par logiciel
taillés à la main jusqu'à aujourd'hui
donc j'ai pu beaucoup développé ma
production qui ce que vous pourrez
bientôt retrouver sur les marché forain
de saint pierre que je met aussi à la
disposition pour l'heure actuelle pour
mes clients sur les réseaux sociaux tels
que facebook
instagram
mais il me reste vraiment encore à
développer la partie vente de mon
entreprise
j'étais parti de rien à ma majorité donc
là je vous renvoie justement sincères et
je dormais sous les ponts je n'avais
personne sur lesquels m'appuyer je
n'avais pas non plus de repères j'étais
quand même consciente qu'il fallait que
j'avance
malgré tout donc j'ai eu recours à
plusieurs métiers jusqu'à ce que naisse
ma première fille et là ça a été
vraiment déclic qu'il a fallu que je lui
donne l'exemple et j'ai profité pour
réapprendre ce métier et il m'a fallu
s'étend jusqu'à aujourd'hui pour le
mettre vraiment en place est arrivé
jusqu'ici voulait pas premier nous les
plates dernier non plus c'est ce que ma
grand mère me répéter toujours et c'est
ce qui m'a permis d'aller de l'avant